In 1999, a daringly original sci-fi film became
the must-see hit of the year and launched
one of the most successful trilogies of all
time.
The Matrix.
Now, two decades later, another sequel is
on the way.
So grab a spoon, pick a pill, and find out
everything there is to know about The Matrix
4.
"All I'm offering you is the truth.
Nothing more."
Though no release date has yet been revealed,
we have some pretty good guesses.
Variety reported that the new Matrix film
is scheduled to begin filming in early 2020.
Considering how long it takes to film, edit,
and create digital effects for a movie like
The Matrix, the release date likely won't
be until the summer or fall of 2021.
That would be in keeping with tradition.
The Matrix and The Matrix Reloaded hit theaters
in late March 1999 and mid-May 2003, respectively,
while The Matrix Revolutions, shot immediately
after Reloaded, made its way to theaters just
six months later in November 2003 so as to
not keep fans waiting for the trilogy's conclusion.
Keanu Reeves, actor, officially became Keanu
Reeves, legend, thanks to his turn as Neo
in The Matrix.
For most fans, if there's no Neo, there's
no point to a new Matrix film.
Well, don't worry, because Reeves is reportedly
signed on for The Matrix 4.
And he'll also be joined by co-star Carrie
Anne-Moss, who became a Hollywood sensation
as Trinity.
So far, though, there's no word regarding
the return of other Matrix stars like Hugo
Weaving, Laurence Fishburne, or Jada-Pinkett-Smith.
For now, we'll just have to wait and see.
It wouldn't be a Matrix movie if the Wachowskis
weren't involved.
After turning heads with the stylish 1996
crime drama Bound, Lana and Lily Wachowski
made themselves legends with The Matrix in
1999, and went on to co-write and co-direct
the entire trilogy.
So will they be involved with the new Matrix?
For now, the answer is yes… and no.
While Lily Wachowski apparently won't be involved,
Lana Wachowski is set to direct, and co-write
the script with author Aleksander Hemon and
Cloud Atlas screenwriter David Mitchell.
Warner Bros.
Picture Group head Toby Emmerich said,
"We could not be more excited to be re-entering
The Matrix with Lana.
Lana is a true visionary - a singular and
original creative filmmaker - and we are thrilled
that she is writing, directing, and producing
this new chapter in The Matrix universe."
One thing conspicuously absent from Variety's
August 2019 report announcing the launch of
The Matrix 4 was any mention of Laurence Fishburne's
character Morpheus.
Variety reporter Justin Kroll later tweeted
that this may actually be a hint as to the
plot of the film, writing,
"If you've asked yourself, 'Where's [Morpheus],'
sources have told me this may point to where
and when the film is set as I've heard execs
are looking at a variety of actors to possibly
play 'young [Morpheus].'
Stay tuned on that front…"
The fact that Morpheus might be played by
an actor younger than Fishburne suggests The
Matrix 4 takes place in a different time - or
in a different timeline - than the original
trilogy.
And it also suggests they've decided to scrap
the previously rumored Matrix reboot as well.
Yes it's true: back in March, 2017, The Hollywood
Reporter broke the news that Warner Bros.
had started preliminary development of a reboot/relaunch
of The Matrix.
After original Matrix producer Joel Silver
approached Warner Bros. with the idea of a
revival, the studio reportedly began discussions
with X-Men: The Last Stand and Incredible
Hulk screenwriter Zak Penn to write a detailed
narrative plot outline.
The Wachowskis were not involved with that
project, and no actors were ever signed, but
initial reports hinted that Warner Bros. would've
liked to cast Creed star Michael B. Jordan.
Now, though, with director Lana Wachowski
and stars Keanu Reeves and Carrie Anne-Moss
all set to return to the world of The Matrix,
it seems as though that reboot project is
dead - killed off by the original.
"Ironically, this is not far from the truth.
Do you believe in fate?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.